delta variant has health officials on
alert for the uptick in covid cases
nevada reporting more than 100 confirmed
cases
christian costa is joining us in studio
to break down why this has become such a
problem
brian the delta variant is a mutation of
the kovitz strain and according to an
infectious disease expert at unlv
we can expect more variants like this
one in the coming years today we spoke
to brian lubis
an infectious disease expert at unlv
school of public health
he says the biggest difference between
this strain and other strains is what
it's basically it spreads more easily
there have been no reports of it causing
different diseases
deadlier or more hospitalizations
according to him it's all about the
person-to-person spread which of course
will lead to more transmission
in the community because it's so
contagious he says the only way to know
if you have the delta variant
is through a specialized test at the
state public health lab
a normal cova test will not tell you
what strain you have
he says it doesn't change how you are
treated but it's important for tracking
the variant
well we're going to continue to see
different variants popping up that's
just the way viruses spread
their copying mechanism isn't perfect so
there are changes that
build up over time and if one of those
variants spreads more easily than the
strain that's the dominant strain now
that one will basically out-compete it
and take over as the dominant strain so
we're seeing more and more delta-variant
cases
well the cdc and the southern nevada
health district are not modifying face
mask mandates like those in la county
they recommend everyone vaccinate
vaccinated or not to wear a mask
in large gatherings now he says people
should be more concerned the people who
should be more concerned are those who
have not been vaccinated because
basically they have no protection
so check out eightnewsnow.com to
schedule your vaccine christian casadas
8 news now